-Our first guest tonight i
a Tony and Emmy Award-winnin
actress
who you know from shows
like "The West Wing" and "Glee
and the Broadway productio
"Wicked."
She stars in the new serie
"Schmigadoon!,"
with new episodes streamin
Fridays on Apple TV+.
Let's take a look.
-You know what?
We are both outraged
by these outlandish allegations.
-The only outrageous thing her
is your behavior,
which has now, officially,
been deemed as unseemly
by the
Mothers Against the Future
Therefore, no one --
and I mean, no one --
in Schmigadoon
will give you lodging.
And, Harvey, don't even thin
about letting them back in
after I've left.
I can read you like a book
Oh, wait, books have spines.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter stops ]
-Please welcome back to
the show, Kristin Chenoweth.
Hello, Kristin!
-Hi, honey.
-It's so lovely to see you
-You too, man. I've missed you
-Your wardrobe is the physical
manifestation of your spirit
[ Laughs ]
-You know what, Seth?
I thought,
"I'm bringing it, Seth.
I don't care.
No more jackets and no makeup.
I'm bringing it just
to the "Seth Meyers Show."
In fact...
-Look at that, top to tail
Yes! No sweat pants on Kristin
Thank you.
-No, I'm bringing it to you,
Seth, okay?
-We -- Don't think it will b
unappreciated by everyone here
Thank you so, so much.
-[ Laughs ] You're welcome
And by the way,
I loved, in "Ya Burnt,"
when you said the delta variant.
Yesterday, I flew Delta
to get to L.A.
And I love Delta, okay?
Like, I love Delta Air Lines
I'm not ashamed to say it.
Why must they call it
the delta variant? Why?
-Yeah, you know
who has no sympathy?
The good people at Corona,
who made the beer.
[ Laughter ]
They're like, "Okay."
They're like, "Oh, is it har
for you, Delta?"
[ Both imitating crying ]
So, first of all, before I ask
about "Schmigadoon!,"
a lot of people
learned new skills.
A lot of people had to fin
new platforms for their talent
You found your way onto TikTok
during the pandemic.
How did that come about
in the first place?
-Well, you were talking
about TikTok-ing this morning.
-Yes.
-I was unaware about --
I'm not that lame,
but my boyfriend was like,
"You've got to do TikTok."
And I was the crazy --
not crazy, but, you know,
insane person running around
with Lysol and
singing high notes.
And unfortunately, I was doing
it in a Winnie-the-Pooh onesie
because why wear
anything with a waistband?
-Right.
-So, he said these would b
great TikToks,
and you know, he was right
I'm ashamed and yet -- and yet
I'm thrilled, because...
[Sings high-pitched note]
I walk around, spray,
wear my Winnie-the-Pooh onesie
and, you know, it's a hit.
What can I say?
-Look, if TikTok wasn't
built for that,
what was it built for?
-[ Laughing ] I don't know
-So, that's you being very
modern, very of-the-moment
"Schmigadoon!" is
a lovely throwback
to, sort of, these style o
musical from the '40s and '50s
It seems like this was a perfect
match -- you in this project
How did it come about?
How were you approached for it
-You know, I know
that you understand
that, especially in New York -
New York was so hit --
right? -- with the pandemic.
I think, the hardest,
in my opinion.
And Barry Sonnenfeld called me
And I'd had a lot of loss
at the time.
And he called me and said,
"I want this new show."
And I'm a huge fan of Cecily's
And obviously, Alan's one of
my best friends, and Dove.
I wanted to do it.
But I just didn't feel
I had it in my spirit.
I just thought,
"I don't know if I can."
He goes, "You have
an 18-page song,
and we're going to do it
in one
take."
Now, he knows me.
This is my fifth project
with him,
and I went, "I'll be there."
So, that's how it happened
And it was the hardest thing
I've ever done, and the most -
it was so fun.
It was so fun.
-You basically do,
inspired by "Ya Got Trouble"
from "The Music Man,"
and so this isn't
just an 18-page song.
This is like an 18-page,
single-spaced patter song.
-Thank you for knowing that.
-And I would imagine it's harder
when you film it.
Even though you can do
multiple takes,
this was done in one take.
-Yes.
-And that is --
I mean everything you do
onstage is, obviously, one take,
when people see you on Broadway.
But how is it different
doing it with cameras and crew
around?
-I got really good friends
with camera A operator Jim
We practiced, you know --
I don't know if you heard,
but we wore cones.
Like, we wore cones and masks.
I felt like I'd been spayed.
But it was fine.
I didn't care, Seth.
I showed up for rehearsal.
I said, "Jim, follow me."
I gather the town.
So it wasn't just
that I was doing
an 18-page patter song.
Thank you for knowing
what that means.
But I was also
gathering the town,
so I've used the entire set,
and one mistake
means back to one.
And I thought, "It's not going
to be on my dime or proble
if we mess up."
So I practiced
in my hotel room, by myself,
yabba-dabba-dooing around,
like a freak,
doing "Tribulation."
It's called "Tribulation."
-You mentioned, when you'r
yabba-dabba-dooing
in your hotel room
that you shared a wall
with your friend Alan Cumming?
Is that correct?
-I hope we're still friends.
Yes.
-[ Laughs ]
He's a night owl, as am I.
But, he's -- I'm much --
I go to bed at like 5:00 a.m
He goes to bed
at like 2:30, 3:00.
And I would wake up in and
literally try to go to sleep
and I'd be like, "We've go
tribulation, my good sir.
We've got tribulation
in Schmigadoon."
And I'd do it in the bathroom,
because there's high notes, too.
And I wanted
to hear myself really good
Every soprano knows,
you practice in the bathroom
And I'd hear bang, bang, bang!
-[ Laughs ]
-"Shut up!
[ Laughter ]
"Shut the -- Shut up!"
And then,
at like 8:30 in the morning,
he'd be, like, doing his song.
You know, and I'm like,
"I can hear you!
I just went to bed."
This was during quarantine
I mean, but that being said,
he beat me --
he got out of quarantine
three days before me.
And when I was done,
he was there
and took me --
He's vegan, you know.
Which is fine, but I'm not
And we went to a vegan diner
We had dinner.
He took care of me.
I -- I -- I love him.
-It's a very -- It strikes m
that you guys have
a very nice friendship.
He did tell a story about yo
that I now need to verify,
'cause it's
a pretty memorable story
about you sending muffins
to someone.
-Okay. With --
I have to just say,
yes, I saw him tell the story,
and I died 1,000 deaths.
But one of my friends, she
used to run the theater wing
I was unaware
that she had passed.
Her family reached out and
said, "We're honoring her.
-Mm-hmm.
-I was doing my -- I was young
I was doing --
not paying attention.
I had a deal with
Mrs. Beasley's.
Thank you, Mrs. Beasley's.
I sent Mrs. Beasley's cookie
to the...
-The honoring.
-It was her funeral, Seth.
[ Laughter ]
It was her funeral, Seth.
And Alan Cumming
loves to tell it.
He also loves to tell
when I very first got invite
to my first fashion show,
this was -- I'm dating myself.
A very, very famous
designer woman
sent me a bunch of clothes
Well, you know I'm 4'11."
You know my size.
It's hard for me to --
So, she sent nothing that fit,
except this one cute --
really cute skirt.
So I thought,
"I'll add my own jacket."
I got to sit next to her.
And when I saw her,
she goes, "Hmm, inventive.
I thought,
"She doesn't like my shirt
She doesn't like it.
But nothing fit."
It was later that I found ou
it was a tube top.
[ Laughter ]
And it was in
The New York Post.
-Oh, no!
Did they know it was a tube top?
Or did they think you were being
inventive, as well?
-I hope they thought
I was being inventive.
But her face is kind of like..
-[ Chuckles ]
-This was like 1999.
What are you gonna do?
-Look, everybody
was tube-topping in '99.
-[ Laughs ]
-And you couldn't
walk in New York City
without bumping into
somebody wearing a tube to
as a dress.
Hey --
-But as a skirt.
-As a skirt.
So I've asked a lot of Broadwa
veterans about this question
about the fact that Broadway's
opening up again
and what they're
most excited to do.
And a lot of people
have told me, you know,
it's less about
getting back onstage,
which they desperately
want to do,
but that they want to be
in the audience again
for a Broadway show.
Is that something that's tru
for you, as well?
-You know, just like you,
you're doing your show,
and we listen to the audience,
right?
It's the relationship betwee
yourself and your audience
Same with me
when I'm in a concert
or if I'm doing a role.
I listen.
That's the biggest part
of my job.
When I'm in the audience,
I participate.
So, yes, I can't wait.
I'm going to go --
As soon as I can,
I'm gonna go see "Lion King.
My boyfriend
has never seen the --
He's only seen one -- two
Broadway shows.
I'm going to go take him down.
I'm going to take him
to see "Hamilton."
I mean, I want to -- I want to
celebrate my friends.
I want to celebrate the ar
of music theater and plays -
anything live.
Just like how I know you fee
when you're --
like, you know, "Ya Burnt.
I'm sitting over here
cracking up,
and you can't hear me.
You know what I mean?
-Yeah, we would very --
we should have mic'd you.
That was a big mistake.
It was real quiet in here.
-You should have, because
I was laughing my butt off
The subway thing, forget it.
-Well, it is always
so lovely to see you.
-Thank you.
-Thank you, as always,
for making time for us.
And I hope, next time,
to see you here in the city.
-Amen.
And my love to your family
And just in case, stay safe.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, good --
good product placement.
"Schmigadoon!" Is currentl
streaming on Apple TV+.